tracie two films went to Sundance this
year 2016 forty years after the death of
Christine Chubbuck why do you think the
sudden interest it's a good question we
were as surprised by that other
Christine film as I think they were
surprised by us but in a way it was kind
of a beautiful beautiful surprise
because it it showed us that there was a
reason that that this had bubbled to the
surface again after 40 years and I think
clearly some of it has to do with the
intersection of news and entertainment
and what that's meant in this country in
particular the way we've seen that
manifested now in our well in every
aspect of life particularly in the
political season we're in right now and
that's pretty scary stuff but you know I
think one of the other things that the
movie is kind of scraping away at is the
way women are the double standard that
the ridiculous standard that women are
held to and it's made manifest in this
movie was we see her struggling in the
workplace and that she's clearly held to
a different standard than the other
people that she's working with that in
fact Christine the film Christine seems
to support the idea that her madness is
not all just an issue of mental illness
bipolar disorder whatever
what however you would classify her
mental illness but also that something
about being woman in that world drives
her a little mad and I think the film
illustrates that well it seems that the
story has not really been exposed I know
I think I'd heard you say in an article
that paddy Chayefsky maybe emulated some
of you know
at work after some of the scenes why do
you think it's been sort of swept under
the rug I know it's a disturbing look at
someone that you would never think was
struggling with those type of issues but
what are you thinking it you know paddy
Chayefsky was so ahead of his time right
genius and visionary but was never
really dealt with yeah I I don't know I
I think that I don't know why it goes
away the the fact the matter is that
because there's no video
it becomes with just the three line
story of what happened to this woman is
such a sad story without anything to
support it if there were video of the
event it would live on in a kind of
gruesome replay of this woman's very sad
and violent act my understanding is that
that video existed that the owner of the
station was offered a lot of money for
that video by the networks and declined
and actually put it in a vault and
sealed it and never allowed anybody to
look at it and I think that's a good and
Noble thing that he did so I'm glad that
video doesn't exist but probably because
it doesn't exist this story has faded
away in light of a lot of other gruesome
footage that's out there that exists in
the world that people can look at if if
they're into it